[Music]
a fifth of companies in the eu
offer their goods or services online and
that proportion is growing
every year parliament is proposing
changes
to better protect our lives online
platforms today and digital services
providers are
have become public utilities we use them
on a daily basis
to communicate to share information to
book a holiday to book a hotel
to make our online purchases but it's
not just the things we buy
it's the personal data we surrender and
the news and information we read and
share
mep say the new rules are based on a
simple principle
if it's illegal offline it should be
illegal online
what must twitter do against the hate
speech and racism
what must facebook do against child
sexual abuse material and what must
youtube
do against terrorist contact
parliament wants a strict legal
framework including fines
to tackle illegal content and for better
oversight of harmful content
it's all about securing fundamental
rights giving consumers a choice and
finally we want to make it easier for
startups
to enter the markets meps reject a
one-size-fits-all approach
and insist big platform should be held
to account small ones should be allowed
to grow
and that consumers should be protected